how's it going bro my name is param at
welcome back to some more the rise of
nightmare let's just do it
alright when I scaping from holy [ __ ]
Kal Penn no-go yeah
Yeah right like about oh [ __ ] bother
them you can kick your enemies taking
nothing doing on it I wish but it knocks
them out ha ha ha ha ha ha back up
oh you to Jennifer Lopez my god alright
bring it you kept the [ __ ] bra that's
your mother just [ __ ] that's how I roll
anyone else huh anyone else wanna [ __ ]
with me
I don't think so all right there we go
that just looks stupid ah [ __ ] the pyro
ready alright [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
whoa what are you doing here don't tell
me bro that's how are you alright anyone
else I'm [ __ ] exhausted how many are
there more of them what are you anyway
Hey Girl hey no it's just you're
disgusting okay luggage luggage
come on stop following me now all right
focus
Pecha blockage [ __ ] now in your face in
your face oh no it's on the other [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this is gonna hurt blockage haha
can I kill this thing
hi what's up diet
oh [ __ ] ow [ __ ] that hurts
okay
how do I tell this thing oh wow okay
fine you know what I'm out of here
I'm out of it I'm so over here please
don't change me Brown native res don't
really love this place
what the [ __ ] am I going [ __ ] am I going
no no all right this way ah
rah it's [ __ ] behind me oh [ __ ] man
stop if that's that ow Jesus Christ
huh oh please let this [ __ ] yes yes yes
no no no
well holy [ __ ] Jesus what the hell is
that
oh I feel like I've been tired night
today no I want it on
[Music]
yeah yeah this Gustafsson if I can
exhaust it already breath mm-hmm don't
even worry about it
I know what I'm doing you can cut up
arms I know that if you take that much
stuff don't worry about it
blunt weapon like aren't suited yeah I
kind of know it that one you just never
[ __ ] know what's gonna happen in this
game
oh no I'm strapped oh no more German
people
oh no beat this John oh dang why would
you do that
Oh is good argument no no I'm not please
I don't think you're done with him until
I guess hello hey it's Felix
yeah you better I'm not yes we I don't
care yeah you get it now I want the
village and then come home and lick my
[ __ ] it's okay you bet they're all
right now why are we okay like don't
worry
all right go don't look back
oh no it's a samba nurse yeah
Oh what is the hell going on here what
the [ __ ] are you alright it's not the
tickets guy this place is crazy but
here's my number so call me maybe
alright and then pretty good sapphire
let me get that machete that he brought
okay good night can i play this the
German looks pretty cool alright let's
go in here
touch your ha alright I think we can go
there check this place out I can use the
rack with that thing alright I'll do
that
huh chef all right what if we got it
again I don't like this go ice and
scallion oh oh stop shut up all right
here we go
whoa thanks
I'm sorry riding me today did I do that
I think I did that oh my god
it is thanks today looks like a nice
turkey I bet he has it did you have the
key
hey Brad did you have the cake okay
don't kill me don't tell me I got it
thank Jesus all right a key for my life
that's how I roll
all right who's next not that way
that's way I like your mustache did I
tell you that Friday I want to stroke
your must add one lifetime
just one lifetime bro all right can
interact with this I bet I can interact
with this though yeah
now what hello yeah mom I gotta go
alright yes this is working way better
than I would walk beside aside something
down there no let me go here then I
don't like corridors they're never good
things our eyes let's indirect I told
you interact breath push shot hi miss
Nicks
alright bucket
hey Brian get the [ __ ] out huh stairs
I love sex so much going down this never
get though going up Miss Emma good
either actually oh [ __ ] it something in
here no [ __ ] it
Oh give me the survival knife give it a
summer look me why are you going bro
[ __ ]
yes that would could kill people I don't
want the Caliphate ball I want to go
home
are you then I don't think those things
are dead
are you dead right dancing I can do that
[Applause]
all right let's [ __ ] kill them hey
what do you want huh
anyone else
[Music]
I'm gonna go forward please is how to
move to this [ __ ] no fan back in bad
game I [ __ ] it
or does this game once we to go [ __ ] you
know stop seem like I'm away bro come on
beer breath when a rough time the run
get your [ __ ] breath whoa
take that take that take that take that
I'm exhausted
wait is he going [ __ ] out the walks
sucks what
I saw I'll take that
all right
no back up haha oh I [ __ ] massacred
them holy [ __ ] let's go down here oh
[Music]
let's go down it's how I roll
[ __ ]
I owe the [ __ ] line
I'm so tired I pass I'm gonna end this
episode here I can fit if you enjoy it
helps out a lot this guy comer birth
today and you know I love it
hi Andy I don't really have that much to
say this week I have more plan next week
all right so I'm just gonna do a Q&A and
from Twitter so I suppose on Twitter to
ask me anything and we'll see what we
can find
so someone asked if they could see a
picture of me when I was a child so here
you go